[лунає органна музика]
Музика, взагалі, — це дуже об'ємне мистецтво,
яке супроводжує людство із найдавніших часів,
і супроводжувати буде завжди.
У Львові є традиція органної музики:
є, так звана, Львівська органна школа,
до якої входять відомі композитори,
у Львові були і є відомі органісти.
У Львові і, взагалі на Галичині,
була велика кількість органів,
було кілька сотень органів на Галичині.
У Львові було багато органів,
зараз залишилося кілька.
І наш орган є єдиним концертним інструментом,
який дозволяє сповна відчути взагалі що таке орган,
і послухати органної музики.
Майже ніде в світі немає окремо залів органних.
Тобто ці реалії: немає в Америці, немає в Австрії,
немає у Франції окремо органних залів.
Здебільшого в Європі це сприймається
як такий церковний інструмент,
виключно церковний інструмент,
або як додаток, наприклад, до симфонічної музики.
Наприклад, симфонія з органом.
У нас же склалася традиція, що орган —
це суто світський інструмент,
і суто концертний інструмент.
І це велика різниця між усією європейською традицією.
Тобто у нас є великий плюс, який склався історично,
що він може бути і духовним, і церковним інструментом,
якщо так можна назвати.
Але водночас він є світський,
і традиція світської музики,
тобто звичайної музики, яку ми всі слухаємо.
Вона розвивається тут більше, ніж в інших країнах світу.
[лунає органна музика]
Тут — особливе місце, і особлива історична будівля.
І чим вона особлива: тут є найбільший в Україні,
і один із найбільших у Східній Європі органів.
[звучить орган]
Він збудований у 1932 — 1933 роках.
Це довго, щоб будувати орган.
Він має три мануали: можна грати руками, можна — ногами.
У чому специфіка?
Ми бачимо: тут є різні труби.
Звук іде від труби. Та?
Там є металеві труби, є дерев'яні труби.
Це є великий мотор, який це все повітря прокачує,
і від натискання тієї чи іншої клавіші —
повітря потрапляє в ту чи іншу трубу.
Їх там близько 4700 різних труб.
Те, що бачать люди із залу, —
це тільки маленька частина.
Там всередині їх дуже багато: від найменших
до найбільших труб, які надають різне звучання.
У чому ще особливість?
У тому, що в ХХ столітті багато органів взагалі в світі
(в Німеччині чи в Австрії) переробляли:
осучаснювали, надавали сучасну електроніку і різні речі.
Оскільки у нас тут нічого не осучаснювали,
то це — великий плюс:
зараз назад повертаються до того,
щоб зняти цю всю сучасну електроніку,
а у нас тут нічого не змінено, збережено у тому
автентичному стані, як було в 1932 році.
Це коштовне задоволення:
ремонтувати орган і за ним доглядати.
Але наша місія — його зберегти і покращити,
і довести його до найкращого стану,
в якому він тільки може бути.
Для нас дуже важливо зробити так,
щоб сюди було цікаво приходити.
Тому що, по-перше, музика має звучати.
Ми працюємо із матеріальною культурною спадщиною.
Це — будівля, це — інструменти.
Порятунок, реставрація, реновація.
Дбати, показувати, мацати,
тому що воно — матеріальне.
І ми працюємо з нематеріальною культурною спадщиною:
це вся музика, яка була колись написана,
яка пишеться зараз чи буде написана.
Тут дуже цікаве ще є.
Зазвичай музиканти лишають помітки.
Нє, мабуть, нема. Нема.
Музиканти в нотах залишають помітки,
бо це строй партії.
Для кожного музиканта є свій.
Зазвичай музиканти залишають помітки в нотах.
Ми брали в Оперному театрі старі ноти
Анатолія Кос-Анатольського — такий був композитор.
«Ой ти дівчино, з горіха зерня» — ця пісня.
У нього був балет «Хустка Довбуша» називався.
У 50-х роках написаний.
І там один музикант із оркестру залишив собі помітку:
«Такого-то числа, вистава така-то,
грав я – такий-то, дирегент – такий-то.
Композитор дав 1000 рублів на кір».
Так і написано «на кір» — на бухло.
І оце так лишилось в історії, музиканти...
Отут є помітка, що це виконувалось у 910 році.
Музикант залишив.
От скільки я музики слухаю,
звичайна людина про це не думає,
але музика постійно є в нашому просторі —
це невід'ємна частина культури.
Тому ми для того тут і є,
щоби розширювати ці горизонти,
щоби люди могли слухати більше,
якісніше, і новіше.
Але слухати музику може кожен.
Кожен, хто може слухати.
Але чути музику — це вже зовсім інше.
Це — навик.
Чути музику, і приходити в концертний зал —
це набута потреба.
З цією потребою не народжуються.
Це потреба, яку нам дає приналежність до культури.
Культурна потреба формує цивілізовану людину.
Цивілізоване суспільство дбає про розвиток культури.
У цивілізованому суспільстві ходять на концерти.
Таке суспільство, яке ми будуємо в Україні, українці,
воно хоче мати розвинуту класичну музику.
Тому що класика — це перевірене століттями,
це щось дуже добротне, це витримане,
це великі і успішні традиції,
це те, що є еталоном доброго смаку.
Наш концертний зал виховує добрий смак.
Ми працюємо над тим,
щоб поганої музики було менше,
і над тим, щоб задовольняти
культурні потреби наших гостей.
Ми тут знаходимось, це є другий мануал,
тут є різні труби.
Як вам видно: вони — і великі, і маленькі.
Це металеві труби.
Тут, ближче від мене, є ще дерев'яні різні,
і, дійсно, дуже вузьке розташування.
Для ремонту, для налаштування органу —
це доволі складно.
Інколи, для того, щоб налаштувати
групу регістрів, групу труб —
потрібно пропихатися, десь пролізати.
Інколи це дуже незручно.
Як там видно — там є, наприклад,
дуже маленькі труби — флейтові регістри.
І кожна труба, наприклад, реагує на коливання тиску,
реагує на температурний режим.
Реагує, навіть, якщо я тут трошки походжу міцніше,
а це вже все розстроїться.
А настроїти таку велику кількість труб —
це непросте завдання.
Тому робота органного майстра —
це дуже сильно.
Ось так.
Були видатні люди, які ввійшли в історію
органної музики України,
які дбали про це приміщення,
і дбали про те, щоб орган у цьому приміщенні звучав.
Хотів би назвати історичних:
це Самуїл Дайч — це був такий відомий органіст зі Львова,
і Арсеній Котляревський,
який згодом працював у Києві.
Вони спричинилися до того,
щоб цей орган працював,
щоб тут відбувалися концерти,
щоб тут відбувалися постійні концерти.
Звісно, коли ми говоримо про той період,
потрібно розуміти, що саме
завдяки зусиллям цих людей,
цей простір не знищений, орган не розібраний.
Тому що схожа доля спіткала більшість храмів колишніх,
які впродовж радянського режиму
закривалися, і нівелювалися,
тобто там сформовували склади,
там відбувалися дуже-дуже різні,
можливо, навіть, нецивілізовані речі.
Тому цій будівлі пощастило у тому,
що нею опікувалися люди, які дбали про мистецтво.
Тому зараз ми можемо насолоджуватися органною музикою,
зараз можемо слухати симфонічну музику,
і зараз ми можемо мати креативний
простір у центрі Львова,
який має у своєму розпорядженні
один із найбільших органів Східної Європи.
І дуже важливо, щоб це місце розвивалося,
тому що його потенціал — шалений.
Це в єдиному екземплярі є.
І твір, який вважався кращим.
Але як зробити так, щоби,
коли це є написано в форматі отаких невідомих значків,
щоб я міг поставити собі навушники у вуха,
і слухати це, йдучи по дорозі?
Як так зробити?
А потім ще вибрати в плеєрі різні виконання?
Тобто це еволюція: від моменту з пожовклого паперу
до моменту вибору найкращого виконання.
І тут — маленька реклама: ми зробили додаток,
який називається «Ukrainian Live Classic».
Додаток є комплексним, тобто його місія —
це комплексно презентувати всю українську класику, яка тільки є.
Ми гордимося, що тут є всі композитори
України в алфавітному порядку:
від сучасного київського композитора Золтана Алмаші,
який живе в Києві, родом — зі Львова, до ...
Отам є Березовський, 17 століття.
Колесса, Кос-Анатольський, Косенко, Козаренко,
Кудрик, Леонтович, Левицький, Людкевич до ...
... Затуловський Леонід.
Цього взагалі мало хто знає.
Затуловського Леоніда.
Коли ви востаннє слухали його фортепіанні концерти?
[звучить орган]
В органному залі досі є багато викликів,
досі є багато сторін для покращення.
Ми хочемо зробити так,
щоби наша мета ставала трошки ближчою,
тобто щоби класична музика
стала ближчою, стала популярнішою.
Щоби потреба в цій музиці
в кожного з нас і вас була ще більшою,
продавати ще більше квитків,
і постійно мати аншлаги.
Тобто це те, що ми хочемо робити,
якщо ми хочемо досягнути [мети].
І, з іншого боку, зробити так,
щоби ми, як жителі нашої країни,
більше знали нашу власну музику,
і наш концертний зал максимально
цьому присвячує свій час.
[лунає органна музика]